hi this is presh talwalkar
can you place the numbers one through
nine in the following three by three
grid so that each row column and
diagonal adds up to the same number
this is a condition for the three by
three magic square
i want you to find all possible
arrangements
and i want you to prove there are no
other ways to do it
can you figure it out
give this puzzle a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
alright
there are 8 different possibilities for
the 3x3 magic square
you'll notice some patterns
every single square has the number five
in the center
the corners of each square are made up
of the even numbers two four six and
eight
the edges are made up of the odd numbers
one three seven and nine
in fact
every single one of these eight patterns
is really a rotation and a reflection
of a single pattern
so what do i mean by that so let's focus
on the magic square in the upper left
i'm going to create a copy of it
and now let's imagine reflecting the
numbers through the middle
so this will transpose the first and
third columns
this brings another magic square which
was the second square in our list
let's make a copy of this second square
i'm going to rotate
180 degrees
and now i'm going to bring the numbers
right side up
this was the third magic square in our
list
let's make a copy of the first square
again
now i'm going to do a reflection across
the diagonal
so this will bring all exchange all the
numbers
that are across the diagonal with each
other
this is another magic square that was in
our list
and you could continue you would
actually find that all of these magic
squares can be obtained by rotations and
reflections or combinations of rotations
and reflections of the first pattern so
they all actually can be obtained from
each other
as a technical note these are actually
correspond to the symmetries of a square
or the dihedral group of order eight
so we're going to prove these are the
only ways you can have a three by three
magic square
and we're going to do that in several
steps
so first we're going to say we don't
actually know a magic square exists but
we're going to come up with some
conditions that if a square exists
certain things have to be true so one
thing is that every single row column
and diagonal is going to need to sum to
15.
so why is that
let's take a look at summing up the
first row
we don't know what it is but we'll say
the sum has to be some constant m
the second row has to have exactly the
same sum
because in a magic row every single row
has the same
sum the third row also has to have the
same sum
so now let's add up these three rows we
have m three times which brings us to
three n
but there is another way that we could
sum up the three rows we know that the
three rows contain the numbers one
through nine used exactly once
so we know that all of the nine rows all
of the nine elements have to be
the sum of the numbers one through nine
so we have the sum of the numbers of 1
through 9 equal to 3m which means 45
equals 3m
and so m equals 15.
so if a magic square exists it needs to
have a magic sum of fifteen
i did this proof using the three rows
you could similarly do that proof using
the three columns
now step two
we know that these
three numbers are going to need to add
up to 15. so now we can try and compute
the different ways we can get to a sum
of 15 from three distinct numbers
let's say we have one as our first
number
and then we want to add two
in order to get to 15 we would need to
add 12
but that's clearly a problem because our
numbers only go up to nine
so we cannot have 12 and therefore we
can't have one and two
at most we could have 1 being paired
with 9 which means the middle number
would have to be 5.
if we paired 1 with 8 then the middle
number would be 6.
so we can go through these possibilities
and figure out there are only eight
distinct ways that we can get these
numbers to add up to 15.
i'm going to put those sums to the side
but this is the crucial step in the
proof we're actually going to be able to
deduce a lot from it for example
this will be able to tell us the center
square has to be five
the center square is involved in the
middle row sum
it's involved in the middle column sum
and it's also involved in the sum of
each of the two diagonals
so the center square is involved in four
different sums of numbers
so what possibly could the center square
be
if we look at our sums
only the number five is involved in four
different combinations
all of the other ones are involved in
either two or three of the combinations
so that means the center square would
have to be five
continuing the reason we reasoning we
can find the corners have to be even
numbers
a corner would be involved
in one of the row sums one of the column
sums and also one of the diagonal sums
so each corner is involved in exactly
three of the sums and this corresponds
to the numbers two
the numbers four
the number six
and the number eight
so we know the corners would have to be
2 4 6 and 8.
and finally
every edge is involved in a row sum and
a column sum
so it's involved in exactly two distinct
sums
if we look at our list of sums that get
up to 15
this would be the numbers 1 3
7 and 9.
so let's put all this knowledge to use
we know that the number five has to be
in the center
we can put the number one
right above it we can put it to the left
of the five we can put it below the five
and we can put it to the right of five
opposite the 1 we would have to have 9
in order to get to 15.
now in the perpendicular row or a column
we can put the number 3 in two different
spots if you focus on the square in the
upper left we can put the three to the
left of the one
or we could put it to the right of the
one
we could put if you look at the lower
left square we could put the three
above the one
or we could put it below the one
so in each one of these possibilities we
can put three in two different spots
that are perpendicular to wherever the
row or the column that the one is
and now we're gonna have to fill in the
nines and the sevens
from
the ones and threes that we've put in
because seven has to be opposite three
and nine has to be opposite one
so these are a total of eight different
possibilities to put the odd numbers on
the edges
and in fact that's the only way that we
can arrange this
the odd numbers were involved in exactly
two sums so that means the remaining
sums are the even numbers
and they're forced by the arrangements
we've already made
so these are the eight different magic
squares they actually do work these all
add up to 15 in each row column and
diagonal
and so we've proven that eight of them
exist
and by the conditions we set up these
are the only squares that could be a
three by three magic square
as we've shown earlier these are all
unique up to rotations and reflections
so the three by three magic square is
really cool it's only one pattern
and the rest of the patterns are related
by being reflections and rotations of
the square
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mindyourdecisions which you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description